one day I saw the picture of the Buddha
on the Buddhist magazine I had the
desire to be someone like like him if
you think that the compassion making you
weak you have wrong it's very powerful
if you are too unstable if you are not
solid we are not happy need motivation
watch top ten with the leave nation
what's up believe nation it's heaven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference in the world so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from growing up wanting to be a monk and
being exiled by Vietnam during the war
to publishing over 100 books and being
nominated for the Nobel Peace Prize by
Martin Luther King
he's tick not Han and here's my take on
his top ten rules to success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one find your beginner's mind one day I
saw the picture of the Buddha on the
Buddhist magazine and he was sitting on
the grass how old were you
seven eight and he was sitting on the
grass very peaceful who's smiling and I
was impressed around me people were not
like that so I had the desire to be
someone like like him and I noticed that
kind of desire until the age of 16 when
I had the permission of my parents to go
and add a NASA investment did your
parents encourage you or were they were
locked in for this to happen to you in
the beginning they were reluctant
because they thought that the life of a
monk is hard difficult so this desire to
become a monk started when you were
seven years old yes and what did that
feel like what did those urgings that
sense of this is what I must do or must
become what did that feel like I would
not be happy if I cannot become a monk
and that is the feeling and we call it
the beginner's mind beginner's mind
yeah the deep intention deepest desire
that one person may have and I can say
that since that time until this day this
beginner's mind is still alive in me it
has given me a lot of energy courage in
other confront all kinds of difficulties
that I encounter how would you describe
beginner's mind is it is it that that
desire is it is it your purpose
or is it your calling everyone has
desire when they desire to transform
oneself the transform ones affliction
suffering in order to get free and help
other people and change the world that
is a good desire yes yes it's what a lot
of people refer to as passion when you
were passionate about your work yes yes
it's the way I feel about my work most
days and you enjoy and I enjoy yes and
so if people follow their passion it's
like following their beginner's mind
rule number two my personal favorite
have compassion if you think that the
compassion making you weak you have
wrong compassion may cause a man a
person who sacrificed his life to save
other people and we have to really find
what is compassion it's very powerful
and we have to embody that kind of
energy you know you know in our daily
life we had to radiate people about this
you have to show what compassion can
achieve when when someone is angry he's
been burned by the fire of anger and if
he knows how to practice compassion
anger will die down very quickly and it
looks much better much more beautiful
much much more attractive that is why we
had to example 5 is embody that practice
of compassion in order to persuade other
people to to do the same compassion help
us to sleep well compassion protects us
better than guns and bombs and money
many of us think that we are safer to we
if we have more money but you can lose
your money very easily
but compassion is a kind of energy that
can help protect you much much more
effectively than than money
and compassion help you to relax and
your body has more capacity to heal
itself compassion help you to be
pleasant to be loving and you can
restore communication with other person
easily if you have compassion in
yourself you understand the other person
your compassion can help you do your
business better because you are in good
relationship with other people including
your employees so you can list a lot of
qualities of compassion and we should
have a man a woman a community of men a
woman practicing community practice
income combustion like that in order to
show people that compassion is something
very powerful rule number three stop
seeking other people's approval
you know that the notion of beauty
differs with every person something can
be very beautiful to someone but not
before through any to other people so
their notions of beauty beauty or
ugliness their notion and you are not
affected by their by their opinions you
are a flower in the garden of humanity
you are not something less than a flower
in the garden of humanity you belong to
the kingdom of God like any other
wonders of life and if you have that
insight that you know if if you know
that you have the seed of compassion of
joy of God of happiness in you and then
you know that you know that that you
have a value that and if you believe in
the existence of that these qualities
[Music]
transmitted by your parents ancestors
and you have continuation of optimum and
opinions people who have are you will
have no effect you still continue rule
number four be open to the mystery of
life when people look at the cosmos look
at the planets and look at the life in
different forms they ask the question
what is the meaning so everyone is
trying to find a meaning of life the
meaning of life is nice not something
objective verifying
that is our way to look and to find a
meaning if I believe that if you you
have you have an idea about the meaning
of life you may be caught in that idea
so you should all out just have to be
open in order to continue to get in
touch with the wonders of life and you
will discover more and if you have
already an idea about meaning of life
then that month may be a kind of
obstacle for you to go more deeply that
it is possible for you to to be fully
present in order to in order to be in
touch with all wonders of life and that
has a capacity to to nurse you to heal
and by doing so you might deepen your
understanding of the mystery of life but
if you live in such a way that that
brings so much craving and anger and
despair you will lose yourself and you
miss the chance in order to to be in the
here and now and that you know that will
be in touch with the wonders of life
rule number five transform suffering
people afraid of being overwhelmed by
something and they lose the hope the
creations there must be a way to live in
order for you to be strong enough
in order to handle the suffering inside
of you and if you don't know how to
handle the suffering in inside of you
you cannot help another person to suffer
less and that is why the practice of
mindfulness first of all is to help you
yourself to suffer less first of all you
have to learn how to release the tension
in your body how to reduce the pain in
your body and the practice of mindful
breathing mindful walking sitting
meditation total relaxation can be very
helpful in reducing the pain in your
body and then with the practice of
mindfulness you can you can learn how to
create you generate a feeling of joy and
hope and of happiness of happiness and
this can be done by anyone if we want to
learn fortin's when you breathe in and
if you focus your attention on your
in-breath and then you can bring your
mind home to your body and there is the
energy of mindfulness concentration in
your in-breath and you realize that you
are alive because someone who is already
dead doesn't breathe in anymore
so I wanna impress that my last three or
four seconds can create mindfulness
concentration and insight and when the
body and mind are together you are
established in the present moment in the
here and the now and you can get in
touch with the wonders of life that are
available in the here and the now
and and with that time mindfulness and
concentration you realize that you are
lucky enough luckier than many people
you have enough conditions to be happy
right now right here and you don't have
to run into the future to look for
happiness and that happens after three
or four seconds or practice of mindful
breathing you get the insight that there
are conditions of happiness that are
available in the here and now you are
very lucky you are alive inside can can
happen just after a few seconds of
practice and the fact that you can
recognize and embrace your pain can
bring you a relief because the pain is a
kind of energy and mindfulness is
another kind of energy this energy
embracing the other energy will make
produce a kind of change like a mother
holding her baby the baby suffers the
mother does not know yet what is the
cause of the suffering of the baby but
the fact that is she's holding the baby
tenderly can make the baby suffer less
right away because that there is the
energy of tenderness from the mother
penetrating into the body of the baby
that that bring relief and if she
continues with my for holding and she
will find out the cause that make the
baby suffer and then kisses she can
change in the situation rule number six
be aware of your
body how did you love yourself first of
all receive my phone and you become
aware that you have a bottle within him
I know I have a body the body is real
important part yourself you spend two
hours with your computer
we are stressful and you don't know how
to stop and you forget completely that
you have a body very deep
you are looking for something in the
future in your work while your body
suffers so the first act of love is to
breathe in and to go home to your body
within I know I have a body
hello body I'm home I take care of you
so to be aware our body is to beginning
a block and when mine is home to to body
mind and body I established here in the
lab rule number seven have a strong why
you know one day I go is practicing
walking meditation in a park in France I
I saw a young lady young mother with a
beautiful baby and in a flash I thought
that if I was not a man I would have a
wife and a child like that but that idea
only lasted for one second I thought I I
knew right away that my mission my life
is a monk and is very strong and I I
don't get lost in this kind of deviation
of the bind yeah yeah of deviation of
the man so it was just a flash a
flashing moment and having seen a woman
and her I recognized it and I overcome
it very quickly
really yes and other than that never
thoughts about it or a question did I
make the right decision or what could
have been you know I think because that
intention is so strong that it can
protect but it can keep you alive yes
rule number eight cultivate stability
see myself as a mountain
a mountain represent stability and
solidity a person cannot be a happy
person unless she has some stability he
he has some stability and the practice
of mindful breathing mindful sitting
mindful walking can always help us to
cultivate more stability and solidity
and our selecting our stability is
something we can offer to the person we
love if you are too unstable
we are not solid we are not happy we
cannot and the other person suffer also
because of that so cultivating stability
and solidity
is something you can do Rula benign get
rid of anger and I think the first thing
we do when anger is about two is to go
back and be in line because anger is
like a storm they can't it has there are
symptoms if you feel that anger is
coming it's coming up from down there in
the bottom of our consciousness
so when
when the storm is about to break out we
know we feel signs of the storm so you
have to prepare in order to be able to
[Music]
to resist afternoo witnessed all so when
anger is about to come up it might take
two or three seconds to come up so
during the time we have enough okay
occasion in order to go back our
breathing and breathe in and instead of
focusing ourself my anger we focus our
mind on our back we are not afraid of
anger because we know how to handle and
to deal with anger first of all we have
to breathe in and focus our attention
away we focus our attention on our
in-breath we bring our mind home to our
body we are truly dead yes strong enough
to take care of ourselves and rule
number 10 the last time before a very
special bonus clip is practice tea
meditation we have the practice of deep
meditation Oh tea meditation yeah so
when you pick up your tea you might like
to receive in order to bring your mind
back to your body and become completely
fully present in the here and now I
don't think of the past anymore
I don't think of the future anymore I am
free from the past from the future and
there is a real encounter between me and
a tea and peace happiness enjoy is
possible during the time I drink my tea
well I never had that much thought about
a cup of tea it takes one hour to just
enjoy a cup of tea a cup of tea like
this yes when our Brown Brotherhood and
sisterhood and every woman is a moment
of happiness
now I've got a really special bonus clip
on how to listen with compassion that I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that I want to know what did you
learn from this video what message
really resonated the most with you how
are you gonna make a change in your life
or your business after watching this
video write it down in the comments when
you write something down you're much
more likely to actually follow through
so put it in the comments thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
deep listening is the kind of listening
that can help relieve the suffering of
the other person you can call it
compassionate listening you listen with
only one purpose help him or her who
empty his heart and if you remember that
you are helping him or her to suffer
less and then even if he say things full
of wrong perceptions full of bitterness
you are still able to continue to listen
with compassion because you know that
listening like that with compassion you
give him or her a chance to suffer less
if you want to help him or her to
correct his perception and then you wait
for another time but for this the time
being you just listen with compassion
and help him or her to suffer less and
one hour like that can bring
transformation and healing if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it don't you believe it you
act like I counsel what a wail out of
handcuffed lightning though Thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I've murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 254
days I will be sending you a video
between thirty seconds and five minutes
long that you start your morning with
around making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access